House Republicans appear to be United in
their opposition to the Omnibus Bill so
the big question is what will Senate
Republicans do this package contains
billions in pork and woke handouts
provides border security for Middle
Eastern countries but doesn't guarantee
much for our own and emboldens Biden's
bureaucrats all while undermining
American prosperity and it's all
happening just weeks from when a new
house majority will take power here with
more House minority whip Steve scalise
uh whip scalise I had the honor and
privilege of serving with you in the in
the house I've been down this path with
you before because it's Nancy Pelosi's
policy basically take it up till
December 23rd everybody wants to get
home it's Christmas there's bad weather
what can House Republicans do at this
point other than hope that the Senate
you know stalls this bill what's the
plan
well Jason we're fighting it we're
whipping against this bill but we're
also exposing just how many bad things
are in this bill and I think that's
where the country is getting engaged and
you know you just mentioned through Chad
pergram that Mike Lee is going to
attempt an amendment uh to try to
reverse what the administration is doing
letting title 42 expire I hope Mike
Lee's successful but there's absolutely
nothing in this bill for border security
uh hundreds of billions of dollars
nobody can tell you what's in it it was
just filed and they're going to vote on
it in dark at night it would it would be
ironic but uh but appropriate that they
would try to vote on at three in the
morning this is a bad Bill for taxpayers
but we've got to change the way that
business is done in Washington it's what
we ran on we won the House Majority on
that but you see them running this thing
through by dark of night with billions
in things that they're doing border
security in foreign countries in their
impeding border security in our country
everything about this is the wrong way
to go I hope they reverse course
now Mitch McConnell said there were two
choices but isn't there actually a third
choice I mean aren't the House
Republicans encouraging to say why don't
we just do a continuing resolution come
back after the new year and continue to
address this and don't do it the week of
Christmas
that's exactly right it's a third option
that would at least keep things going
but not have all of this pork all of
this new spending that nobody can
explain nobody can tell you what is in
it because they were just throwing
things in it was like a Christmas tree
being thrown together and lit up right
at the end of Christmas and and it's a
lot of coal it's not a lot of gifts
right now
now my understanding is there's
something like 7 500 ear marks is that a
practice that once Republicans have the
majority in the house you continue to
support and will will there be earmarks
in a republican-controlled house
one of the things we've talked about is
actually changing the way the entire
Appropriations process works you know
and as Majority Leader I've already laid
out a schedule working with Kay Granger
who's going to be the chair of the
Appropriations Committee so that we can
actually pass all of the bills through
the house before summer get them over to
the Senate but we need to lay down a
marker early that the Senate has to do
their job and not wait till the Midnight
Hour this has become a problem that's
gone on for years now where the Senate
Waits until September 30th they just do
CR after CR short-term funding bills
because they know they can wait until
Christmas Eve throw something together
in this big Omnibus Bill where they have
everything under the sun that nobody can
read we have to change that way of doing
business and we have to lay that market
down early but we've built a calendar
where we can get our work done earlier
too and make it clear to the Senate
we're not doing this things are going to
change I wish they would change right
now and that's why we're actively
working against it and exposing all of
these items that are in the bill that
people are still to the stage just
finding out about
well a little over two weeks the the
Republican hand is strengthened I don't
know why we're not doing everything we
can to delay it until January 4th but uh
you're in the house Congressman so uh
have a Merry Christmas glad you're there
and the halls of Congress uh doing what
you're supposed to be doing uh
Congressman scalise thank you very much
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else